Good morning, John.
I had pretty much the worst anxiety dream
of all time last night. It's pretty horrible
- I don't really know if I want to share it
with you, but I guess I'm going to because
that's what I want this video to be about,
is anxiety.
So yeah, this is bad, prepare yourself: I
dreamt that I was a pilot of a commercial
jet and I crashed it - me, I did it, it was
my fault - and then I had to go to all the
funerals of the people who died and talk to
their families and look at their coffins.
Give me "showing up to class in my underpants"
any day; I will take "didn't go to class all
semester long and now I have to take the final,"
sure. I actually still have those. If you're
in school and you're like, "Oh, I can't wait
to get out of school so I can stop having
these school-based anxiety dreams," that never
happens. You will always dream that you didn't
go to class all semester long and now you
have to go, uh, take the final. That will
always happen to you. Forever. Until you die.
Our brains are stupid.
Turns out, according to a landmark study that
was completed in 1985, anxiety is the most
common emotion felt in dreams. Which makes
me wonder whether or not anxiety is, in fact,
the most common emotion felt total. I'm feeling
like, right now, anxiety is my most common
emotion.
There's a lot going on for me right now. I'm
about to finish my album, Ellen Hardcastle.
I'm very excited... but also scared. I've
been working on it for a long time and I'm
really emotionally invested in it. There's
a lot of my, like, time and passion and energy
have gone into it, and I know that people
aren't going to hate it, 'cause it's good,
like, I know people are going to like it,
but that's what I know. What I feel is that
everyone is going to hate it, and they're
all going to leave me comments saying "Why
did you release this piece of crap out into
the world? You are such a bad person!"
Also, I'm making a video with NASA, which
is just like, "What?!" All the moments of
my life where I'm not thinking, "Oh my gosh,
this is so cool," I'm thinking, "Oh my god,
don't screw up."
I'm officiating a wedding this weekend for
a couple of my best friends, so yeah. My rational
side is like, "Oh my god, what an honor, you
guys really like me that much?" But my irrational
side, all it heard was, "Hey Hank, do you
want to, uh, not screw up the most important
moment of our lives?"
And I'm playing a show with Harry and the
Potters tomorrow night. Playing shows is always
scary, more scary when you're playing it with
the coolest people ever. If you live in Missoula,
you should come to that. There's a link.
And then of course you have the most stressful
thing in my life, which is VidCon. There's
ten thousand things at VidCon, let's just
assume, around ten thousand. Failure rate
of one percent: super good. But when you've
got ten thousand things, it means that some
things are gonna break and go wrong and fail.
And when I'm me and I'm looking, all I see
is the little fail-y things, and I think that's
all that everybody's gonna see. But of course
what everybody sees is the 9,900 things that
went really right.
And yeah, I know most of you are like, "Shut
up about VidCon! I can't go, and it's already
sold out." But, uhhh, next year, 2012, we
are going to have a much bigger venue.
So all this made me realize that doing stuff
is really hard, especially when you're doing
it for other people and you care what they
think about you. Which is why I think that
there are so many sociopaths and psychopaths
in positions of power: because those people
don't care about other people. So when they
do these big, important things, they're not
freaking stressed out as hell, like ripping
their frickin' faces off 'cause they're so
scared. Because they don't care, because they're
psychopaths! And then we're shocked when they
send pictures of their penis to random interns.
No! We set the system up for this. It's way
too scary to be in a position of power, unless
you're a psychopath.
So that worries me. Like if you want to do
big, cool, interesting things, either you
have to be a psychopath, or you have to be
really stressed out. And I don't want to be
either of those things, but I also don't want
to stop doing cool stuff.
Sorry if I'm opening the window of my soul
here, but now I'm going to tell you why it's
different for me and how rare this is, that
the people I'm doing stuff for, they care
about me and they're understanding. And wow
- that's a very unique and awesome gift and
I thank you all for it. And I also thank John
for it, for making me stronger without freakin'
stressing me out, which he never does.
Speaking of which - he's not feeling well,
so everyone send warm wishes to John. Uh,
he's got some stomach problems, which is why
he has not eaten his sandwiches yet. So John,
feel better, and I will see you on Wednesday.